But today we wanted to
begin with Mr Lock part too.
And I said at the end of class last time,
I want to speak a little bit about Locke
and let's just call up the spirit of
capitalism.
And then I want to move into the
issue of government by consent.
Uh,
along with the idea of natural law,
uh,
perhaps one of locks,
clearly central,
perhaps most most significant
contribution to political philosophy,
the doctrine of consent and
various problems that I want to,
to examine with you today,
uh,
associated with,
with consent and what it means to see,
to consent to government,
but the first five chapters of this
tech and treat us if you take them as a
unit.
And,
and I think they should be,
uh,
they tell us a story.
Block presents us,
uh,
so to speak with a kind of philosophical
anthropology that takes us through the
state of nature,
the state of war,
the creation of private property.
And in the fifth chapter,
particularly lock begins,
as I mentioned last time with uh,
the,
you might say the original
condition of nature,
which forms a kind of primitive communism
to the creation of property through
the work,
uh,
of ones,
the labor of one's body and
the work of one's hands.
And by the end of the fifth chapter,
we have the creation of really a kind
of full scale sophisticated market
economy,
uh,
replete with various,
inequalities,
perhaps even some larger scale inequality,
qualities of wealth and property
all within the state of nature.
How did this occur and
most importantly for lock,
what makes this legitimate?
Uh,
what,
what legitimizes this,
uh,
this,
this transition,
so to speak,
from the original state of nature,
governed by nothing more than a law of
nature to the emergence of property.
And in a way a kind of
market economy in many ways,
what Locke is doing in the first five
chapters of this second treatise is re
telling or maybe better rewriting a,
the account of human beginnings,
uh,
that had originally belonged to scripture.
He tells the story,
doesn't he?
Right of how human beings
finding themselves in a
condition of nature with no
one or no authority to adjudicate their
disputes and governed only by a natural
law.
How they are nevertheless able to
create and enjoy the use of property,
uh,
created and acquired through
their labor and work.
Man,
he tells us in these opening chapters
is a property acquiring animal,
the inquisitive animal.
Uh,
even in a state of nature
where there is again,
nothing but the natural law to govern
a human associations and relations with
one another.
But the problem with the state of nature,
a four lock and as to some degree it
is four was four hubs as well is it's
instability,
uh,
with no civil authority
to umpire disputes,
especially disputes over property,
the peaceful enjoyment and
the further acquisition of
property.
The fruits of one's labor are continually
threatened by war and by conflict.
How can we ever be secure in our person
or property with no enforcement agency
to resolve breaches of the peace,
uh,
where everybody is so to speak.
Again,
the judge and jury and
executioner of the natural law,
the need for government arises out of
the real need to resolve conflicts or
disputes over property rights.
Uh,
in many respects.
right.
This sounds like a very familiar idea
that government exists for the sake of the
protection of property rights.
It's sort of a kind of cardinal doctrine
of what I suppose we would call today
libertarianism.
Uh,
the philosophy of,
of libertarianism.
Uh,
so important in,
in a lot of American thought.
Locke is in many ways
the first writer of my,
uh,
familiarity who claims that Ms,
these are his words,
the great in chief end of men's uniting
into Commonweal's is the protection of
their property.
No one prior to lock a,
at least to my knowledge,
I think it ever said in quite such a
bold and straight forward way that the
purpose of politics was the protection
of property rights and buy property.
Uh,
lock doesn't mean simply,
uh,
objects around us that we
have turned into property.
But property is,
is rooted.
Each tells us first and
foremost in our persons,
in our bodies.
We all begin the life with a certain
rudimentary property if only in ourselves.
Property for him implies
more than simply real estate.
Uh,
but everything that encompasses our lives,
liberties and possessions.
These are our property,
uh,
in the original,
and in many ways most revealing
sense of the term property.
That is to say things proper to us.
Is this okay?
You with us?
Okay.
Uh,
but lock continually emphasizes to us
the uncertainty of the state of nature
because life there he says it's full of
fears and continual dangerous that lead
us to civil association.
But think in a way how different locks
account of the transition from the state
of nature to the civil state
is from Hobbs is in many ways.
Again,
as I said,
lock tries to modify,
domesticate,
ameliorate hubs is harsh.
Teachings hubs had emphasize the absolute
fearfulness of the state of nature.
The state of nature was for hubs,
a kind of state of existential dread,
absolute fearfulness for for lock.
However,
it is a condition continually
be set by unease and anxiety.
To use the word he often
uses inconveniences.
Uh,
the state of nature is one that
consists of continual inconveniences.
Uh,
it is our unease are restlessness,
uh,
that is not only a spur to our labor,
but is rather the cause of
our insecurities that we have,
uh,
in the state of nature.
What is it about lock?
What is it about his account?
And I don't mean what is it about him
in some psychological or personal or
biographical sense,
but what is it in his writing that
leads him to emphasize the restlessness,
uneasiness,
and you might say perpetually anxious
character of human beings in the state,
in the state of nature.
Yeah.
Do we ever hear Plato or Aristotle,
uh,
discussing the fearful or
anxious or restless character of,
of,
of human psychology?
I think not,
uh,
was this simply a function of locks?
Nervous disposition was the fact that
he was simply prone to reticence and a
kind of fearfulness in the same
way that Hobbes himself said,
or there's locks emphasis on the
uneasiness of our condition in the natural
condition really represent
the qualities of a new class.
Uh,
the new commercial classes,
uh,
as it were seeking to
establish their legitimacy.
Locke's second treatise
in many respects is,
uh,
a work of middleclass or as
the Marxists would like to say,
perhaps the bourgeois,
uh,
ascendancy when lock writes that he has,
he does that the world is intended
for the use of the industrious and the
rational.
Yes.
Who was he talking about there?
Who are the industrious,
uh,
and the rational?
He is speaking about a new middle class
ethos whose title to rule rests not on
heredity or on tradition.
He is not referring to a
customary ruling class,
a class whose title to rule comes
from its claims to nobility,
but it's,
but he's referring to people whose
title to rule or potential title to rule
rests on their capacities for hard work,
thrift and opportunity.
Uh,
as a former student of mine
who took this class once said,
Locke's
second treatise could well be
called the capitalist manifesto
or the Anticosti.
The anticommunist manifesto
may be one put it,
but as Locky aneurysm,
simply Machiavelli with the human face,
put it that way,
uh,
isn't the rule of the prince.
And Machiavelli,
uh,
the rule of a new leader,
a new,
uh,
sovereign authority,
new authority of some sell,
some sense who operates outside the
parameters of traditional authority isn't
Locky and ism like
Machiavelli in some way.
Uh,
the ethic of the self made man,
uh,
with all of the
insecurities and anxieties,
uh,
restlessness that being self made,
represents,
uh,
does Lockey aneurysm represent in some
ways that the tranquilliser [inaudible]
of Machiavelli turning
Machiavelli's fierce warlike ethic,
uh,
the ethic of conquest and domination
to in fact the ethic of work.
And,
and is it where the
conquest and domination of,
of,
of work through,
through labor and,
and our heart and our
hard work is this again,
simply machiavellianism
with the human face,
but in any way,
I think,
or what I want to suggest
is that lock locks,
political philosophy gives expression
to what the great German sociologist Max
Faber.
You,
you know him?
Yes.
Faber,
you read him in intro sociology?
No.
Okay.
Well,
uh,
you will,
vapor,
uh,
his famous book called the Protestant
ethic and the spirit of capitalism in 1904
1904.
Great work.
Classic work.
And in that work,
a vapor argued that the
capitalist ethic made a high duty,
a moral duty,
turned it into a moral calling,
a religious calling,
the duty of limitless
accumulation of capital.
Uh,
and this was in four in Weber's term,
the outgrowth of the Puritan and
Calvinist movements of the 16th and 17th
Century for vapor.
It was the Protestant reformation that
had taken root in the countries of
northern Europe.
And particularly with the roots
of this capitalistic ethos.
First developed and again adapted a wholly
new moral attitude to such things is
property,
property acquisition,
and moneymaking.
Previously,
these things had been deemed
to be morally dubious,
shunted aside something
shameful about this.
You can certainly see this
and the classical writings,
political philosophy that we did
for these early moderns.
Uh,
capital accumulation became a kind
of high calling and moral duty.
God gave the world to the
rational and the industrious,
not he says to the
quarrelsome and contentious,
not that is to those prideful aristocrats
who seek to struggle for domination
and power,
uh,
over over one another.
What lock brings into being is again,
a wholly new and revolutionary moral
attitude towards property and property
acquisition.
And again,
finds its expression,
great expression a century later with
Adam Smith and of course from Adam Smith,
we have the whole world
of modern economics.
So how many of you are potential
economics majors in here?
I bet more than one without John Locke,
there would be no modern
discipline called economics book.
Cause he was the one,
again,
a century before Smith and the rise of
the school of political economy who made
the first and decisive move,
which was to,
uh,
in many ways make respectable and even
more than respectable make turn into a
high moral calling and dignity,
uh,
the,
the to the acquisition of property and
turned government turning politics into a
tool for the protection of
property and property rights.
That that is the significance in
many ways of what Locke has done.
And I want to talk,
probably not today,
but,
uh,
next Monday on some of the,
in many ways,
pros and cons of,
of this immense moral transformation
regarding property in economics that Locke
had helped,
has helped to bring into being.
But for the rest of today,
what I want to focus on is locks,
idea of consent.
The idea that the origin
of all government,
or at least all legitimate,
all legitimate government is
said to derive from consent.
The consent of the governed,
an idea that was implicit in some
respects in Hobbs is theory of this,
of the social,
of the covenant that
creates the sovereign,
but for a wit,
but to which lock gives in many ways,
much greater pride of place.
In chapter eight,
a of the second treatise
lock gives us there.
He provides us with a kind of
hypothetical reconstruction,
uh,
of the origin of society.
So Paul's Society,
she writes it night,
section 95.
The only way whereby anyone divest
himself of his natural liberty and puts on
the bonds of civil society is by agreeing
with all others to join and unite in a
community for their comfortable,
safe,
and peaceful living.
Uh,
lock tells us there's something about the,
that the legitimate
ends of society for the,
the,
the ends that civil society,
uh,
serves comfortable,
safe and peaceful living.
And he goes on to affirm that whenever
a sufficient number of people,
uh,
have consented to make a single community,
and I quote him again,
they are thereby presently incorporated.
And to make one body politic,
they make one body politic
were in the majority,
have a right to act and conclude
for the rest were in the majority.
Have a right to act and conclude for
the rest of that short statement.
Section 95 of Chapter Eight,
uh,
seems to make maybe the first and
most powerful case for democracy.
Okay.
Uh,
on the basis of that statement,
a famous Yale professor of at
least a couple of generations ago,
wrote an extremely important book that
made John into a majority rule democrat.
He said in that book that locks philosophy
provides the faith of the majority
rule Democrat largely
focusing on sections 95,
96 as sort of the key two locks,
political teaching,
uh,
in the second treatise.
Does anybody know the name of that?
A man who wrote that book by any chance?
Famous Yale political
scientist event back,
back awhile ago.
Nobody.
Not Nobody remembers.
Wellmark Kendall's book on luck.
Okay.
You know,
you know it.
Yes.
You were shaking your head
no you don't.
Okay.
Whatever.
It's not important.
Not,
not important.
I just mentioned it in passing,
but consider the,
consider the following
sentence again also,
that seems to add a to this claim for
when any number of men by the consent of
every individual make a
community they have their,
by made that community one body
with a power to act as one body,
which is only by the will and
determination of the majority.
Uh,
what are we to make of this assertion?
And in many ways continued assertion
that lock is that in any community we are
ruled by the majority,
uh,
to be sure that idea,
what if come as an immense surprise,
no doubt to the King of England to
learn that his rule was justified by the
consent of the governed or if you had
done something like cross the English
Channel and,
and go to,
to the France of Louis
the 14th of this period,
uh,
Louis the 14th who famously said lay
toss saying why I am the state no doubt
would have been very surprised
and probably found laughable.
The idea that his legitimacy came from
the consent of his subjects who had ever
thought such a thing that
government derives from the
consent of the majority is
lock in saying that,
uh,
denying the legitimacy of all government
or governments that do not derive from
the consent of the majority.
Uh,
is he on the basis of this truly
a kind of majority rule democrat?
Does he undercut,
for example,
something like Aristotle's argument
who had seen any number of forms of
government is equally a legitimate,
uh,
in many ways so long as they
are moderate and ruled by law,
uh,
or is lock saying again that there is
only one form of government one again,
legitimate or just form of government,
government by the majority.
That's what he appears here to be saying.
And I mentioned this sense appears,
uh,
lock is a slippery fish.
Uh,
he's a slippery writer.
He has a tendency of take back with
one hand what he gives with the other
[inaudible].
Yeah.
Uh,
the agreement
to join to make one community is he
calls it however is not the same thing.
Exactly.
Uh,
it's establishing a form of government
in many ways choosing to have a
government,
which is what lock has caught,
is talking about here in these
relevant sections in 95 and 96.
And so I'm choosing to have a
government to be one people,
uh,
so to speak,
is in many ways an act prior to electing
any particular form of government to
rule you.
The second treatise in some way,
a specifies only that governments derive
their just power from the consent of
the governed.
It does not seem to say very explicitly
about what form of government people
might wish to consent to.
In many ways.
The second treatise one wants to say
is even rather neutral two forms of
government.
The only form of government that seems
to be absolutely ruled out unlocks
account is some kind of absolute monarchy.
We cannot see our rights
entirely to another individual,
but he seems to be relatively
open to whatever it is.
People may wish to consent to.
The act of consent alone
does not create a government.
Uh,
it is merely an act of forming society.
in many ways.
He accepts Pope's famous dictum,
Alexander Pope's famous dictum,
you know,
for farms of government.
Let Fools contest what air
is best administered is best.
In other words,
you'll have the best thing
that administers government
that protects your rights
to property and what form it is,
whether it's monarchic,
aristocratic,
uh,
Republican or whatever is not
as much is not so important.
What is important and for Loc about,
the only thing that is important is that
that form of government received the
consent of the governed.
And of course,
people don't necessarily
have to consent to democracy.
Uh,
if,
if lock is democratic in that way is,
it is only because,
uh,
he's democratic.
Uh,
in a sense that government
derives the authority from,
from consent.
It does not necessarily
have to be democratical,
uh,
inform,
in that respect.
But it is this idea of consent and you
will no doubt talk about this and your
sections.
It is this idea of government as
being by consent that has so much,
uh,
insinuated itself.
I'm not sure that's the right word,
but as so much,
uh,
formed in many ways the
cornerstone of American,
uh,
the American regime and American
political thought in many ways,
even more,
I would suggest than his doctrine of
property and property rights locks,
doctrine of consent,
uh,
is what,
captured the imagination
of the American founders.
Uh,
when Jefferson wrote about
the ends of government,
he said,
the ends of government
are to protect life,
liberty,
and the pursuit of happiness.
He seems in some ways he seems to
modified locks statement about life,
liberty,
and to state.
Why did he do that?
Uh,
we could talk about that.
And of course,
what is meant by the pursuit of happiness
certainly is intended to entail a,
among other things,
a Pr,
the acquisition of property.
But Jefferson in some ways
sort of elevates lock locks.
Language Locky and language does
not simply focused on property,
but the pursuit of happiness,
uh,
in many ways,
however,
construed consistent,
uh,
with,
with the rights of others.
But it is locks,
language of consent,
uh,
that the just powers of
government derived from consent,
uh,
that seems to have most,
um,
inspired,
uh,
Jefferson and the founders.
And through that doctrine,
it of course had a huge effect on
America's greatest second founder.
Uh,
Abraham Lincoln.
Consider the following
passage from Lincoln.
This is Lincoln in 1854
in his first major,
uh,
speech,
first most important speech,
sometimes called the Peoria speech
where he was already debating a Stephen
Douglas,
Steven A.
Douglas.
Uh,
it was for the Senate campaign,
uh,
in,
in Illinois appropriate in our
time of the year where they were,
they were then arguing
as they would again,
uh,
if for the presidential campaign argue
over slavery and cure is what Lincoln
rights when the White Man governance
himself that is self-government.
But when he governs himself and also
governs another man that is more than self
government,
that is despotism.
Lincoln says,
my ancient faith,
no dead thinking about
declaration and Jefferson's ideas,
my ancient faith teaches me that there
can be no moral right with one man making
a slave of another.
What I do say Lincoln continues here
is that no man is good enough to govern
another without that others consent.
This he concludes is
the leading principal,
the sheet anchor of
American republicanism.
So there is Abraham Lincoln referring
to the doctrine of consent by which he
says that no man is good enough to govern
another without that others consent.
Calling this the leading principal
or the sheet anchor of American
republicanism.
That statement
as I suggested a moment ago as part of
his debate with Douglas over the issue of
slavery,
and in many ways cut to the
car of the meaning of consent.
Douglass also in some respects,
tried to derive his view,
his views from an idea of consent.
What Douglas said was,
uh,
that regarding slavery,
he said he didn't care.
It was a matter of indifference to him
whether people of a particular state or a
territory wanted slavery
or didn't want it.
Uh,
whatever they wanted that is to say
whatever the majority consented to was all
right with him.
Uh,
he might prefer it not to be,
but again,
it was what people consented
to what the majority wanted.
Uh,
that was,
uh,
the,
that w that would decide the matter.
Uh,
Lincoln however,
had said that the doctrine of consent
is not simply a kind of blank check or a
blank check,
uh,
that the doctrine of
consent still implied.
A set of moral limits or restraints on
what a people might consent to consent
was inconsistent with slavery.
He said,
because again,
no one can rule another without
that other person's consent.
And in many ways that crucial debates,
so fundamental to American history in
politics grows out of a kind of internal
problem within locks,
doctrine of consent.
Namely that problem is what
form of government does it
make sense for a majority
of people to consent to?
Does government,
uh,
in other words,
by consent mean government by
whatever the majority wants,
a kind of could be a kind
of tyranny of the majority.
There's whatever they want
or does government by consent
in tail against certain
limits and restraints on what
majorities can do what guarantees,
uh,
does lock provide?
You might ask that government by consent
will be informed consent or rational
consent.
Uh,
can people simply consent to
anything to be ruled in by any means?
This is obviously not an
idol or a purely theoretical,
uh,
questions.
Since popular majority's,
we know,
uh,
in the world today,
popular majority's can choose,
uh,
to be miss.
They can choose on the basis of whim
will or some other kind of arbitrary
passion,
unless there seems to be some set of
moral restraints on what individuals or
majority's can consent to.
Uh,
what is to prevent a majority from
acting just as despotically or just as
arbitrarily is a king
or any absolute power.
That is,
was the question that
Lincoln was raising in his,
uh,
argument against Douglas
and his claims about,
about consent.
But this question of restraints or
limits on what people can consent to
raises a
yeah.
Or leads to another question
about the doctrine of consent.
How is consent conferred?
We are citizens of the oldest
democracy in the world,
most of us.
So I guess,
I don't know,
maybe not everybody,
but most people in this room are citizens
of the oldest democracy in the world.
Did anyone ask you for your consent?
Uh,
or may considerably older,
but,
uh,
you know,
I have never,
uh,
did anyone ask for my consent?
The idea of giving consent to a form
of government implies something active.
Uh,
an emphatic voice.
but his,
anyone since the first
generation of founders who
ratified the constitution ever
been asked or required
to give their consent to,
it might ask,
what is locks answer to this problem?
It is,
and it is a problem
that he is aware of and,
and struggles with in
that important chapter.
His answer turns out to be something
quite different from our views about
citizenship
and who is a citizen.
And how was the consent of the
citizen conferred on government?
In section one 18,
he writes,
a child is born a subject
of no country or government.
Yeah.
In other words,
he's saying citizen is not
citizenship is not conferred by birth.
Uh,
this being born in a place does
not make you a citizen of it as,
as
okay
doctrine that we hold every person.
Uh,
lock continues,
uh,
is born free and equal in many ways
in this kind of state of nature,
under the authority only of their parents.
Uh,
what government that person may choose
to obey is not a matter of birth,
but of choice.
And again,
lock seems to be making some kind of
active principle of choice or decision,
uh,
a principal of citizenship
and the conferring of,
of consent.
And it is only,
he says that when a child reaches
what he calls the age of discretion,
18 or 21 or something like that,
that one is obligated to choose to some
sign or mark of agreement to accept the
authority to accept the
authority of government.
Lock is not altogether clear
about how such a sign or a mark,
uh,
is to be given one suspect
from what he is saying.
He may be referring to some kind of oath
or some kind of pledge or some kind of
civil ceremony where one vows
or pledges with one's word,
with one's word,
uh,
the acceptance of the form of the state.
Nothing can make any man.
So lock rights,
it is to say an actual citizen of a state.
Nothing can make any man so,
but his actually entering into it by
positive agreement and express promise and
compact.
He says at one 22,
uh,
by express promise and compact such
an express promise or agreement,
uh,
leaves one,
he says perpetually in indispensably
obliged to be and remain unalterably a
subject of it that is to the state.
So once you give your word or agreement,
Locke says you are perpetually and
indispensably obligated to that state.
That's how seriously locked
takes this idea of consent.
It's something that can only be
entered into at the age of discretion.
It must be given consciously,
fully,
rationally,
presumably in some kind of ceremony.
And once given your consent to the
form of government remains as he says,
perpetual and Perpetual,
uh,
you are,
you are bound unalterably as he puts it.
Uh,
there's no such thing as taking it back.
It shows you how important lock puts
on the word or the oath or some,
some kind of civil,
uh,
agreement.
One's word is one's bond,
uh,
to give voice or consent to government
is not an act to be entered into lightly.
He says or implies.
But it is a kind of lifetime commitment
and it also shows us how different locks
view of the citizen is from ours.
In other words,
it would seem for Locke,
the only people who are full citizens
in our country would be people who have
given their active consent.
And the only people who have given
their active consent are people who have
undergone what we interestingly
caught kind of naturalization process.
Is anyone here,
is anyone here a naturalized
citizen as we call it?
Has anyone ever been to
a naturalization process?
No.
Nobody where,
uh,
people go to,
you know,
it's administered by a judge and a,
you swear allegiance,
uh,
to,
to the new country.
You've presumably,
you shed your obligations
to your previous country.
You swear your allegiance to this one.
The only that seems to be the kind of
thing lock lock appears to be talking
about.
And it's interesting that again,
the only people in our society and our,
in our country who would be
full citizens would be uh,
uh,
w w w net naturalized citizens.
Again,
birth alone does not confer on you
citizenship of any particular of any
particular country.
But what does that mean
for the rest of us?
Those who have not given
their active consent,
uh,
lock is aware that not everyone
gives their active consent.
That's why he introduces another
idea for how consent may be given.
He talks about what he
calls tacit consent.
Uh,
there are those maybe who have not
sworn allegiance or given a civil oath,
but who nevertheless can be said to have
given their tacit consent to the form
of government and its laws.
But how do we give tacit consent?
Tacit consent is a strange word because
consent implies something active and
open.
Where tasks set.
Think of loc tasks.
Aternity tasks that's a,
implies something closed or concealed.
How is tacit consent,
uh,
given that's a problem,
that lock you can see lock
working on to some degree.
He says,
anyone who simply enjoys
the protection of the law,
the security of property and person
under the law can be said to have given
their tacit consent.
Uh,
they give it so to speak.
X Silencio even there,
there's silence.
Confers consent.
But how do we really know?
You could say,
how,
uh,
how do we know that,
silence confers tacit consent and
silence is not simply silence.
Uh,
an example I think of,
for example,
if you go to wedding ceremony or,
and I guess in some wedding ceremonies,
the,
uh,
justice or the minister,
whoever says,
you know,
whoever,
uh,
w what is the phrase about,
whoever,
uh,
hold your peace.
You know,
if anybody has any,
uh,
any question about this ceremony,
speak now or forever,
hold your peace.
And of course everybody's
except in the movies of course.
Uh,
uh,
everybody's always silent.
Nobody says it's so their consent,
you might say their
tacit consent is given.
Uh,
there's silence from their silence,
uh,
to that question there,
their tacit consent is given.
But again,
that's,
that would be one way,
but a against,
how do we know,
again,
when silence confers tacit
consent or silence is simply,
is simply that silence.
It just,
it's an issue that lacks struggles with
and to be sure never fully or I think
satisfactorily resolved.
Maybe you will resolve it.
Maybe you will resolve
it in your next paper.
Uh,
if you have the opportunity to write
about consent and the difference between
the express and tasks,
that form of citizenship.
And also the question being which
lock alludes to but does not fully or,
or there's not quite answered.
Is there any difference in privileges
in civil privileges between citizens who
have given their expressed consent?
And those who have only been said to
tacitly consent to the form of government,
does he suggest that one
class of citizens has more,
has greater rights or more greater
responsibilities than the other?
You might look into that question too.
Uh,
and see if you think Locke suggests any,
any differences on that
lock to go back.
Uh,
and just kind of begin to
wrap this up for today.
Lock does not appear to endorse
any particular form of government.
And in the second treatise,
uh,
the task of forming the government,
will fall to the decision of the majority.
But again,
what farm?
The majority we'll,
we'll decide remains to some degree.
Uh,
and open a question.
What gives lock or Lockie aneurysm?
It's distinctive tone.
It's distinctive voice,
uh,
is the claim that whatever kind of
government a majority decides upon,
it must be one that limits
the power of the sovereign.
We cannot.
Uh,
and this I think in this respect,
I think luck is far closer to Lincoln and
he was just Steven Egg Douglas consent
does not simply mean consent to arbitrary
rule does not mean consent for this
power of the sovereign to do anything.
Lock Locke's theory of constitutional
government is a theory of restrained
government of constitutional
restraints of rule by law.
Uh,
this is lock gives in many ways,
uh,
the importance of law and
constitutional restraints,
what we would today call,
I suppose limited government.
He gives us far greater expression,
far more powerful expression
than any of his predecessors.
They're certainly not hubs who
had attributed absolute power,
uh,
to government or even to Aristotle who,
in many ways to share some
resemblances with Loc.
But even Aristotle had
severe doubts about a rule.
Rule of law.
Hobbes,
Locke is,
is absolutely confident,
uh,
that,
limited government,
uh,
restraints restrains restraints on power.
Whether that power be from the one,
the few,
or the many.
Restraints on power is the only kind
of government that can be trusted to
protect rights.
And in one of the few jokes that
appears in the second treatise,
you might've missed it because
lock is a subtle jokester.
He doesn't,
he's not like Machiavelli or Plato
lock as a very understated jokester.
You know,
he was an Englishman after all.
Uh,
he writes in section 93,
referring to Hobbs Hobbs,
but you'll,
you'll also see his,
his wonderful animal references he writes
in Hobbs is if men quitting the state
of nature entered into society,
they agreed that all of them,
but one should be under
the restraint of laws.
Thinking about Hobbs is Leviathan,
but that he should still retain all the
liberty of the state of nature increased
with tower in,
made licentious by impunity.
He goes on to say,
this is to think that men are so foolish
that they take care to avoid what
mischiefs be done to them
by polecats and foxes,
but our content nay think it
safety to be devoured by lions.
The love the lion being the uh,
being,
being the,
the,
the Leviathan Salvin.
Whereas in the Lockian state of nature,
human beings are like Paul cats
and foxes there noxious creatures,
he says,
but you know,
they're not truly dangerous to you.
And when one enters the state of nature,
when one leaves the state of
nature to enter civil society,
one is certainly not doing so to empower
a sovereign with Elian like powers over
you as he says,
uh,
who,
who would do this?
It's better to have some kind of
theory of restrained government,
government limited government,
uh,
to,
to do this for you.
What I want to do,
I'm going to end on this note.
What I want to do on Monday when I wrap
up lock is to continue with his doctrine
of limited government because there is,
it turns out there is a very
important exception to it.
There is a kind of escape clause and I
would encourage you as you read it to pay
particular attempt attention to
chapter 14 of the second treatise,
his chapter on what he
calls prerogative power.
That doctrine that has very,
very important in grave
implications for our politics today.
Uh,
it's a very important chapter and I
want us to continue this and then talk a
little bit about the pros and cons
of locking in political philosophy.